Окрім прикордонних катерів - військові кораблі
У вересні Україна вперше за усі роки Незалежності
почала помітно збільшувати свою військову присутність
в Азовському морі
Після того, як ми втратили таку базу як Севастополь
військово-морських сил Збройних сил України
керівництвом держави прийнято рішення про формування нової військово-морської бази
і визначено саме Азовське море
До цього часу на Азовському морі не було інфраструктури ВМС
Це корабель "Донбас" – найбільший за водотоннажністю
у військово-морських силах України
У Маріуполі його називають
головним захисником міста
Разом з ним у морі присутні ще 9 кораблів і катерів
ВМС і Держприкордонслужби України
Українськівійськові визнають,
нині "перевага" на боці Росії
За різними даними, йдеться
про співвідношення 1 до 10
Ми бачимо нарощування присутності
корабельно-катерного складу
саме морської охорони ФСБ РФ
Також спостерігаєтьсяприсутність і кораблів ЧФ РФ
В азовському морі присутні
понад 100 суден ФСБ і ВМС Росії
Збалансувати сили Україна хоче за рахунок створення москітного флоту
Це малі, швидкі, маневрені, броньовані
із сучасним озброєнням судна
які можуть ефективно захищати узбережжя
торговельні судна в умовах неглибокого Азову
Відповідно до нещодавно ухваленої Стратегії розвитку ВМС
цей план Україна хоче втілити до2035року
Конкретні кроки поки не прописані
Але на думку морського експерта Ігоря Кабаненка
Україні вже сьогодні потрібні в Азовському морі
щонайменше 50 малих катерів
І зволікати із закупівлею дуже ризиковано
Якщо ми не втілимо цих заходів,
ми маємо серйозні шанси того
що в нас можуть бути наслідки для територіальноїцілісності
негативні, нові негативні наслідки
для територіальної цілісності
суверенітету держави і так далі
Не буває такого, щоб існував вакуум,
особливо на морі
Він завжди заповнюється, заповнюється іншими або іншою державою
Москітний флот із сучасним озброєнням
може коштувати Україні
щонайменше 150 мільйонів доларів
Цих грошей у держбюджеті поки не передбачено
Перемови з країнами-членами НАТО
про закупівлю суден або технологій їх виробництва
далекі від завершальної стадії
У Маріуполі активно тренується батальйон територіальної самооборони
Ці чоловіки мають контракти зі Збройними силами України
які передбачають, що у разі нападу на місто
вони мають стати на захист
поряд з військовими і Нацгвардією
За останні чотири роки, за даними Донецької військово-цивільної адміністрації
навколо Маріуполя встановили кілька ліній оборони з відповідними спорудами
Але рівень загрози для міста і з суші, і з моря
все одно залишається дуже великим,
вважають місцеві активісти
Якщо проти нас працюватиме авіація, якщо буде масована артилерійська атака
то боятися варто, місту дістанеться жорстко
Через це є страх за місцеве населення
Якщо так, як в Грозному, ці варіанти,
які застосовувала Росія
то це, звичайно, викликає побоювання
Жителі Маріуполя останні 3 тижні
живуть в умовах воєнного стану
який для них нічим не відрізняється
від останніх чотирьох років життя
в безпосередній близькості до війни
Тут не усі вірять у загрозу відкритої війни з Росією
50 на 50. Я ж усієї ситуації не знаю
Яка там загроза війни! Про що Ви говорите!
Що Путін, що Порошенко
вони обидва їздять до одного дяді в Нью-Йорк!
Ми братні народи і жодної війни не буде
Звичайно, війна можлива!
Особливо після того, що вони утнули з нашими кораблями
у Керченській протоці
Я не сумніваюся в їхніх намірах, проте не знаю,
чи здійснять вони їх
Україна нарощує свій оборонний потенціал
виробляє катери типуГюрза-М",
випробовує нову протикорабельну ракету
Дві команди ВМС вже почали тренування
в управлінні кораблями "Айленд"
які Україна сподівається
отримати від Сполучених Штатів
Можливо, ще цього року або до весни наступного
Жителі Маріуполя сподіваються
що за цей час відбудуться
позитивні зміни на політичному рівні
Наприклад, місію ОБСЄ
розширять на Азовський регіон
Принаймні, Німеччина вже запропонувала розглянути таку можливість